et du côté de la tunisie le
déconfinement a été annoncée pour le 3
mai le pays on rappelle compte pour
l'instant 918 cas confirmés 38 décès
bien moins que dans les pays européens
et si le pays craignent et au début une
saturation des hôpitaux décembre que la
situation était maîtrisée on voit ça
avec notre reporter sur place bassin
chebbi bassam -bonjour alors quelle est
la situation en tunisie l'a écoutée au
début de cette pandémie donc ça fait un
mois maintenant que le payer et
comptines et les autorités tunisiennes
ont vraiment eu peur d'être débordé par
cette catastrophe sanitaire et j'avais
peur de ne pas avoir les moyens de
soigner toute une population si on
venait à connaître un afflux massif de
patients et dans les hôpitaux dans les
grandes villes ou dans les campagnes
le pays est un confinement depuis un
mois à l'heure actuelle on compte 38 et
essai les hôpitaux tunisiens n'ont pas
de taux de connu d'engorgement ni deux
ni de panique qui sont plutôt contents
d'avoir maîtrisé la situation
dès le début et cette situation a
surtout au permis aux hôpitaux aux
tunisiens de faire un petit peu au 9 et
être équipé davantage car il faut savoir
qu'elle optait tunisien a manqué
énormément de structures
d'infrastructures aujourd'hui encore et
beaucoup de dons que ce soit du privé où
que ce soit des dons faits par des pays
étrangers ou même de l'argent injecté
par part par la tunisie par le
gouvernement tunisien a puis un petit
peu restructurer qui sait ces hôpitaux
qui plutôt maintenant sont assez serein
quant à l'avenir et quant à la prise en
charge de nouveaux patients si le cas
est étaient présents qui ne cible comme
vous l'avez dit 38 essais pour le moment
les autorités sont à féliciter pour
suivre ce compliment jusqu'au 3 mai
prochain date à laquelle on connaîtra un
déconfinement progressif alors face
avant on parlait en début de ce journal
des musulmans de france qui commence
aujourd'hui
le rav annoncé le cas également des
tunisiens musulmans
effectivement c'est le cas pour les
cliniciens ici musulmans comme pour les
autres musulmans sur reste la planète
qui s'apprête à vivre un mois assez
exceptionnel est spécial
devoir s'adapter à ce qu vide 19 est
assez de nouvelles mesures de sécurité
ces gestes barrières comme vous le savez
du ramadan et surtout un mois où les
musulmans se retrouvent très souvent en
famille entre amis se retrouvent le très
souvent à la rupture du jeûne se
rassemblent dans les mosquées pour la
prière spéciale à du ramadan tout cela
ne va pas être possible cette année en
tunisie car le gouvernement a décidé de
maintenir la fermeture des mosquées
pendant tout le mois du ramadan pour
éviter tout rassemblement mais le chef
du gouvernement a annoncé lors de son
allocution télévisée il ya deux jours
que des mesures exceptionnelles seraient
prises pour ce mois du ramadan à savoir
le couvre-feu qui passera de 18 heures à
20 heures ou qu'à partir d'aujourd'hui
le couvre-feu est à 20 heures ce qui
permettra aux comédiens de pouvoir
s'organiser de pouvoir obtenir leurs
achats pour la rupture du jeune une aide
supplémentaire sera allouée aux ménages
les plus démunis pour pouvoir tenir
nature en ce mois de ramadhan mais voilà
le gouvernement a vraiment demandé aux
tunisiens de vraiment s'organiser de
faire un effort pour ce mois ci et pour
essayer de maintenir cette pandémie et
ne pas faire gonfler ce chiffre qui est
actuellement de 38 en tunisie mais c'est
ma mercier beaucoup pour toutes ces
précisions